worst you ever tell me about the
injury how was it happened to
to say now is that I had that
always hurts
that is to say normal retaliation with a
exit
they hit me a sniper to point him
so that's not this spark of
Avenue from here to back in row for
l match of bissy out
[Music]
[Applause]
they want to make sure 2011 actually
I was with a lot of people in
protests against the state in the
hour kasbah there were a lot of
world that has lawyers and had likewise
doctors there are business people
and all and also left a plan and
mostly game but it's a
confrontation with the police
[Music]
I was dying because the
military in motion and told us vasile
Up to you
look quickly and where I heard
someone who fell I came for
save him but here they shot me
above
in my neck to the parent agrees who
was next to the avenue church
habib bourguiba
[Music]
how are they and with morphine I
I'm drugged and everything and it's not ya not
of solution but does not want in tunisia
at the political level than at the level of
things they do not want that touched
[Music]
why am I omar because my
knows of lawsuits that I did nothing
as of 2011 there is a big name certainly
in business that with the old regime
and blah blah blah blah you must
he told me that I did that and I saw
that I will kill him who I spent a
present everything but in fact it's my
nature and rediscovered the military too
but he made me a trial of how
do not call you
military service but how I got you
given that I am a handicapped
there was a political use of
some law that was aimed at some
activists and some figures from the
revolution who actively participated
to the revolution that contributed to the
fall of power in place at the time of
power of ben ali we see that some
bloggers people from the artists of the
journalists were prosecuted for
of some laws for oneself to do them
to either scare them or
discourage to continue the fight that
are already started and that continues to
do there is a lot of god they have
now in the present why
because they burned the deposit of
device police at Monday, December 7
2010 29 mashed 2011
he wants to put us in the present
why for simple horizon
what I understand they are
doing their steps
I wanted to ask for political asylum
but after I thought about it and I had to
mount must return to tunisia
you have to continue your fight yeah in
did our bac women reitmans jima early
monday nina young woman has problems
and nice morning we hold the woman to
lawyers
but my god everything went well at
check cost
[Music]
[Applause]
stop
at the end of the period
an annuity now
[Applause]
at
already she
in theory
no
the first time it was for the
cannabis use is the second
times for for the song
I paid to go shopping
third time for the concert we were
singing we finished another
village after they found all the
black world is the fight it's not a
message that for me you see it's a
message for all youth
Tunisian
what type does it tell me I have on the side of
mountains that starts to smoke us who in
arise challenger to the bad guys from
dead of death who Gadhafi like bin al
abadi who turns to apci filou the
mornas doublets mangolo course
normal maradi now that I have
returned to tunisia after four months of
a clandestine in morocco I found
elections the people they are trying
to make the electoral campaign and
everyone is far from everyone
they are looking for that the
chair of the presidency and wealth in
the state
[Music]
j 6 1
m
likewise
the
[Music]
state and culture of the state that
lacks a bit by like other countries
arabic but in tunisia missing a little
respect for laws respect for
institutions
so that pushed a lot of young people to
commit crimes against
policemen against police forces
even bloggers even young people
lasting singers who are arrested because
that there are huge overruns and
it's the confusion between our machines the
freedom
[Music]
each of these fortunes hassan turki
namana trunks louis maury my family
will be dated emanating from the mans bay of
Colombia
Tired
fischer
this morning the cast iron grilles and you
used
major in Morocco goes back to the attacked he
exists but
the political word he says does not exist
the sets is that because I think
that there are politicians and men
at the level in the
the military society and society
homeland security who are involved
in this file
[Music]
I have to settle my situation with the
justice and when there is a possibility
that I will be congratulated as they say
but it's also the same percentage as
I can be in prison I think
it's time to stop these lawsuits
that these people be because they have
contributed to the fall of a jim dictatorship
which is rewarded a few steps from the
time when people were not talking to these
people went down the street everyone has
contributed to the revolution as he can
we will not consider them as
criminals 1
otherwise we will consider all the people
Tunisian as a criminal because he has
shouted a certain moment ben ali clears and
it's not my revolution
conclusion it's just it's a movie
but there
[Music]